all right an unforgettable wine tasting
experience is returning tomorrow the
grand tour presented by wine spectator
magazine is happening at resorts world
and joining us now is kristen beeler the
senior editor of wine spectator welcome
to the show thanks for having me we're
excited about tomorrow night what can
everyone expect when they go to resource
world so tomorrow night is the first of
our grand tour
series and we're hitting three three
cities this year um we're kicking it off
in vegas we have over 200 wineries in
attendance and these are wineries that
have scored over 90 points in wine
spectators blind tasting
process so it's really the best of the
best from all over the world we have
over 14 countries represented including
the us
and
you know we're talking wines from
regions that you know like bordeaux and
burgundy and chianti and then a lot of
lesser known places too like so it's an
educational experience tomorrow too so
you're going in a little about wine you
get educated because you talk to the
winemakers but you said there's 200
different
wines there
how do you tackle drinking 200 different
wines do you have a game plan go into
tomorrow night
sure so first of all what i recommend is
that you taste like a professional which
is how how we taste we evaluate over 12
000 wines a year
so
you can't drink all those wines ah
that's what i've been doing wrong
keyboard is the taste darn it okay so
we're providing splatoons little
personal splatoons for everyone where
you can kind of spit
and that'll kind of help you stay
focused and alert so that you can really
be you know learning and engaging with
the producers um and then i mean of
course you're going to drink some wine
right i recommend starting off with
champagne okay and then finishing at
champagne it's a great palette cleanser
at the end of the evening start and
finish with champagne that sounds like
my god
and then you know it's really tempting
to sort of gravitate to a lot of the
well-known regions the iconic producers
because we have the best and the best
tomorrow night but i really encourage
people to use it as an opportunity to
discover new things um regions that you
might not even know produce wine like
uruguay okay or israel um there's a lot
of discovery to be had what a great
location to a resorts world it's
beautiful over there
ticketing is there different ticketing
tiers for for or one flat fee to get in
tomorrow night there are so the um
there's the general admission
guest pass which is 225 and then if for
a hundred dollars more
you get the vip hour talking about vip
hours
you get an hour before anyone else so
you have an extra hour at the beginning
of the night with access to all of those
producers um before the crowds come in
and then do you get it you get a glass
your wine glass you have one baby
everyone gets a glass they get to take
home with them and we do have food as
well okay yeah we want a little food
we're trying over 200 different wines
tomorrow night before let you go is
there the hot wine for the summer what's
everyone drinking in the summer of 2022.
um i know you work with a lot of wine
wineries but what's the ones that kind
of stand out to you this year uh well i
mean it's summer it's rose season right
season okay and we have a great one
tomorrow night um domain ott from
provence which is sort of the homeland
of rose and they're pouring a phenomenal
rose from the place where rose was
invented so i highly recommend checking
it out i'm gonna put you on the spot
here so someone's going tomorrow night
and everyone's going to want to go and
try these different wines what's the one
they must try we're the first one after
they get their champagne what's the
what's that first one they gotta try
it's hard because we have so many we
have so many unique older vintages that
you would never find anywhere else
um it kind of depends on your palette we
do have a 98 point um brunello which is
a wine from tuscany
bruce anderson our editor who covers
that region gave it 98 points which is
an incredibly rare score for us because
we're pretty conservative scorers
so i have to i know i have to wrap up
real quick the scoring 90s what are you
looking at the texture the coloring the
darkness what do you look at when you
score wine all of those things so we
taste everything blind we don't want to
be prejudiced by producer or price so
all our editors choose everything blind
and a wine that is over 90 points that's
outstanding at that level has
concentration depth
length and really a sense of place so
you know it needs to taste like the
place where it came from i love it
kristen thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate it it's gonna be a blast
wine spectators grand tour is tomorrow
night at resorts world for tickets just
visit the website on your screen and las
vegas now we will be right back